Der zu spät kommt, den bestraft aus dem Leben.
Bitte schon.
Also okay.
Guten Tag.
AK ist mein Name.
Ich bin heute der Diensthabenderarzt.
Ich bin für Sie da.
Kurz zum Ablauf.
Zuerst werde ich Ihre persönliche Daten nachfragen, dann Ihre Bescheidung.
Und am Ende einige Informationen über Ihre Familie.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen,
bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Sind Sie damit einfach verstanden?
Ja natürlich, Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Peter Lindemann.
Okay, können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Peter ist P-E-T-E-R.
Männlicher Vorname.
Und Lindemann ist L-I-N-D.
E-M-A-N.
Lindemann.
Lindemann, okay, ja.
Herr Lindemann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 68 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Am 23.03.54.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin so 1,79.
Und wie viel wiegeln Sie?
Ja, so aktuell noch 74 Kilo.
Okay, Herr Lindemann, danke für die Informationen.
Also, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Bescheid haben Sie?
Ja, mein Hausarzt hat mich zu Ihnen geschickt.
Denn ich hatte ihn angerufen und habe ihm gesagt,
dass ich das auffällig fand.
Heute Morgen war mein Stuhlgang ganz dunkel, fast schwarz.
Und er hat gesagt, ja, da müssen Sie mal dringend in die Klinik gehen,
in die Amulanz.
Und ich habe schon seit 2 Wochen eigentlich so ein bisschen
Bauchschmerzen, so ein Druckgefühl im Oberbauch.
Und zweimal habe ich mich in der Zeit auch übergeben müssen.
Und ich bin schlapp und habe eigentlich nicht viel Appetit.
Und ja, besonders mag ich zurzeit überhaupt gar kein Fleisch essen.
Das ist mir so richtig zu wider.
Und ja, mit dem Darm ist auch irgendwie, ich habe mal Durchfall,
dann habe ich Verstopfung, dann wieder Durchfall.
Das ist also alles ein bisschen durcheinander.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese Vorfallverstopfung
und Durchfall-Episoden?
Ja, das ist eigentlich schon lange.
Das ist bestimmt schon, ja, 4 Monate oder irgendwie so.
Waren Sie deswegen in diesem Periode bei einem anderen Arzt?
Nein, eigentlich, bei dem Arzt habe ich mich nur gemeldet.
Jetzt heute Morgen, weil das mit diesem schwarzen Stuhlgang so irgendwie unheimlich war.
Okay.
Dieser schwarze Stuhl, Herr Lindermann, ist das Therj Stuhl?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt.
Aber das sieht jedenfalls, sieht ganz dunkel aus.
Ganz dunkel und stinkt das?
Ja.
Und ist die Beschlafenheit eher weich?
Ja, weicher, heute würde ich sagen, ja.
Okay.
Aber das wechselt eben bei mir sowieso, ne?
Mal Durchfall und mal Verstopft.
Und haben Sie einen bestimmten Ausbilder für diese Beschlafenheit bemerkt?
Nein, ist mir irgendwie so gar nichts aufgefallen.
Und diese, ist diese Bauchschmerzen ab uns zu oder immer da?
Ich glaube, so im Laufe des Tages ignoriert man das so ein bisschen.
Und ja, beständig ist es nicht, aber immer wieder würde ich sagen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht gemessen,
aber ich fühle mich auch nicht fieberig.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie zweimal erbrochen haben.
Wie hat dieses Erbrechen ausgesehen, aussieht, oder?
Das Erbrochene, wie das ausgesehen, ja, wie das immer aussieht,
das ist ja immer so eine gelbliche Matsche und stinkt halt sauer, ne?
Und man erkennt halt, was man vorher gegessen hat,
insbesondere, wenn man nicht super gut gekaut hat.
Gab es Blut vielleicht?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Oder Kaffeesatziges Stoffe?
Die Kaffeesatzart ist nicht aus, nee.
Nee, nee, das war eher so, so halt, ja, das typische, wie, wie so angedautes Essen im Magen so aussieht.
Okay.
Und diese Bauchschmerzen, wo genau befinden sich diese Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, also wenn ich das überlege, würde ich sagen, so eher im Oberbauch als im Unterbauch.
Also ja, wenn ich also, was, was ich meine beiden Hände so auf dem Bauch lege,
dann würde ich sagen eher bei der oberen als bei der unteren Hand.
Ja, nee. Okay, Oberbauch.
Herr Linke, Herr Seitz?
Nee, ich würde sagen eher in der Mitte.
Mitte, okay.
Und manchmal habe ich sogar das Gefühl, das strahlt so ein bisschen in den Rücken raus,
aber vielleicht liege ich auch nicht so gut, weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe sie akustisch nicht verstanden,
wohin strahlen die Schmerzen aus?
Vielleicht so eher in den Rücken ein bisschen.
Aber das kann ja auch sein, dass ich irgendwie nicht gut gelegen habe in der Nacht
und deswegen ein bisschen der Rücken wehtut, weiß ich nicht.
Eine drückende Schmerzen, ja?
Das sind eher drückende Schmerzen, ja, würde ich sagen.
Und wie stark ist diese Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzkolle von 1 bis 10?
Ja, also so schlimm sind die nicht, sonst wäre ich vielleicht auch eher mal gekommen.
Also ich würde sagen so bei 5 ungefähr.
Okay.
So, dass die Schmerzen wirklich noch so auszuhalten sind.
Okay, haben Sie nachts die weiß ausbürgische Stilfraust?
Sowas habe ich nicht, nee.
Okay, können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja, das habe ich eigentlich schon seit längerer Zeit.
Vielleicht, ja, so seit ich in Rente bin, ne,
dass ich nachts nicht mehr so gut durchschlafe.
Das habe ich schon seit 3 Jahren, 2 bis 3 Jahren.
Ich muss auch nachts immer mal auf die Toilette und Wasser lassen.
Und ja, das fühlt natürlich dann dazu, dass ich nicht gut schlafe, ne.
Wie viel ungefähr müssen Sie auf Sklo in der Nacht?
Ja, 2 Mal eigentlich fast immer, manchmal auch 3 Mal.
Und ist die Farbe rund der Geruch?
Ihre Chance ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, das guckt man sicher nicht so genau an.
Also ist mir nicht aufgefallen, dass das irgendwas Besonderes ist.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich so in dem letzten halben Jahr ordentlich abgenommen.
Erst fand ich das ja noch ganz witzig, aber jetzt, ja, wiege ich nur noch 74 kg,
ich habe halt 84 gewogen.
Also 10 kg habe ich abgenommen in der letzten halben Jahr.
Okay.
Und fühlen Sie sich etwas müde vielleicht, oder?
Ja, so erschöpfe ich mich eigentlich, ja.
Okay.
Ja, müde ja auch, ja.
Sind Sie vollständig gelimpft, Herr Lindemann, auch gegen Corona?
Ja, genau, ja.
Warne Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Im Ausland sage ich nicht mehr.
Herr Lindemann, leider Sie an Feuerkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich schon viele Jahre ein Diabetes,
aber also nur ein Typ 2 Diabetes
und da halte ich so ein bisschen Diät,
passt da ein bisschen auf mit dem Essen.
Ich nehme da keine Medikamente
und mein Hausarzt hat immer gesagt, das ist so gut in Ordnung.
Und dann habe ich seit 5 Jahren ein bisschen erhöhten Blutdruck,
da nehme ich aber auch keine Medikamente.
Das ist halt nur so eine Sache,
dass mein Hausarzt mir das gesagt hat, dass der ein bisschen hoch ist.
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich in beiden Beinen sowohl Knie
als auch Hüftgelenkprobleme,
da habe ich wohl in den ganzen großen Gelenken Atrose,
aber da ist auch noch nichts passiert,
da ist noch nicht operiert oder so.
Im Augenblick schleiche ich da so in der Gegend rum.
Diese Situation ist manchmal sehr schmerzhaft,
können Sie damit klar mit diesem?
Ja, ich bewege mich halt nicht mehr so viel.
Das merke ich schon, dass ich da ein bisschen schonum betreibe.
Okay, Herr Lindemann.
Und welche Medikamente nehmen Sie,
elegantisch oder regelmäßig ein?
Ich nehme eigentlich nur Ibuprofen, wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe.
Welche Dosis?
Ich meine, das sind 400er, ne 600er.
Okay, bei Bedarf, ja?
Ja, wenn die Knie und die Hüftel zu serviert sind.
Okay, ja.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind bin ich tatsächlich operiert worden,
da sind die Mandeln entfernt worden.
Und sonst habe ich aber keine OP.
Okay, sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt?
Ich muss natürlich gucken.
Ach ja, genau.
Entschuldigung, ich bin an einer anderen Stelle als sonst.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich eine Medikamentenallergie.
Ich vertrage kein Novalgin.
Da kriege ich also tatsächlich Luftnot und kriege auch so einen Hautausschlag.
Und wo ich aufaufpassen muss, das hat man dann mal festgestellt,
dass ich auch jodallerisch bin.
Da kriege ich auch Luftnot.
Auf jod, ja?
Jod, genau.
Okay, jod.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Lindemann?
Ja, zum Glück nicht mehr so viel.
Ich habe 30 Jahre lang ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht,
aber vor 10 Jahren habe ich die Dosis deutlich vermindert.
Jetzt rauche ich nur noch 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Aber vorher habe ich schon wirklich ordentlich geraucht, ja.
Wie verstanden habe, seit 10 Jahren?
10 Jahre nur noch 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Und vorher?
Vorher ein Päckchen am Tag, also 20 am Tag.
30 Jahre lang.
30 Jahre lang, okay.
Und dann können Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so abends trinke ich regelmäßig 2 Flaschen Bier
und meistens gar nicht mehr auch noch einen kleinen Schnaps zur Nacht.
Ja, Schnaps, oder?
Ja, eigentlich schon ziemlich regelmäßig, um ehrlich zu sein.
Okay.
Und bitte sagen Sie nicht übel, Herr Lindemann.
Die folgende Frage ist nur eine Routine.
Nehmen Sie irgendwer zu Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein, sehe ich so aus. Nein, nein, keine Drogen, nein.
Okay, ja.
Also Herr Lindemann, wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Wollen Sie sein mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die Kinder, aber die sind erwachsen, die wohnen nicht mehr zu Hause.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
2.
2 Kinder. Also gut.
Sind Sie schon im Renten?
Ich bin in Renten, ja.
Vorher?
Vorher habe ich als Automechaniker gearbeitet.
Automechaniker.
Also ich glaube, Sie treiben keinen Sport, oder?
Nein, nein, also jetzt schon gar nicht mehr.
Früher hatte man keine Zeit und ja, jetzt mit den kaputten Knien
und Hüften, da ist einem nicht nach Sport zumelto, ja.
Ja, das kann ich feststellen.
Herr Lindemann, gibt es wichtige Krankheiten in Ihren nahen Verwandtschaften?
Ich meine hier, Ihre Eltern, Geschwister oder Kinder?
Ja, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Ja, also tatsächlich, mein Vater ist an Darmkrebs verstorben,
mit 65 Jahren.
Und meine Mutter war sehr, war sehr depressiv
und die hat sich dann tatsächlich im gleichen Alter das Leben genommen.
Okay, das tut mir leid, Herr Lindemann.
Und die Kinder sind gesund, hoffe ich.
Die Kinder sind fit, ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Okay, ja, Herr Lindemann, ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen von meiner Seite gestellt.
Ich werde Sie jetzt über weitere Schritte informieren.
Oh ja, das ist gut.
Möchten Sie etwas Fragen oder hinzufügen?
Wenn Sie mir jetzt sagen, wie es weitergeht, dann weiß ich ja Bescheid.
Ja, zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann werde ich Ihnen Brut abnehmen.
Dann brauchen wir noch ein paar Untersuchungen, zum Beispiel Bauchultraschall.
Und dann, bei Werder vielleicht noch einige Vermasse hören.
Und danach werde ich mit meinem, mit meinem Kolleginnen oder auch als Sprechen.
Und nach der Untersuchung werden wir wieder genauer sprechen.
Ja.
Ja, dann können Sie mir dann auch sagen, was ich jetzt gegen meine Bauchbeschwerden machen kann und wie das alles weitergeht.
Das können Sie mir dann hinterher erklären, ne?
Ja, gerne.
Ja, okay, gut.
Okay, dann fürs Erste.
Wiedersehen, Herr Lindemann.
Ja, bis gleich.
Okay.
Ich tippe es denn jetzt noch Frage.
Mich würde mich wundern, wenn nicht irgendjemand hat bestimmt noch eine Frage.
Vielleicht kann man nach Fragen, haben Sie bemerkt Blut im Stuhl?
Ah ja, okay.
Ja, das ist wichtig, glaube ich.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, dunkel, schwarze Stuhl, aber wenn Sie ein direkt Blut bemerkt haben.
Sichtbar ist, ne?
Ja.
Hat er aber nicht gesehen, also auch früher nicht.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie schon seit einer Blutigen erbrechen?
Also, das ist ihm nicht aufgefallen, er hat sich zweimal übergeben.
Ihr müsst aber nicht aufgefallen, dass da irgendwie Blut dabei wäre.
Das hat der Doktor aber auch, da sehe ich gefragt, ne?
Da haben Sie vielleicht nicht gehört, aber er hat tatsächlich gefragt, ob mir aufgefallen ist,
dass da Blut drin war in dem Erbrochenen.
Und das habe ich verneint, ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Immer.
Super.
Haben Sie Leistung, Minderung oder Müdigkeit?
Besonderes True-Zeit.
Ja, also Müdigkeit und Schlappheit auf alle Sälle,
kann man sicherlich auch Leistungsminderung dazu zählen, ja.
Okay, danke.
Kann es weitergehen oder arbeitet noch?
Noch eine Minute.
Ja, alles gut, alles gut, alles gut.
Wir sind ja, wir haben ja Zeit.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Herzgrasen oder ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, ist mir, nein, also Herzgrasen, ich bin nicht aufgefallen, ich bin schwindelig.
Nein, ist mir auch nicht.
Okay.
Gut.
Wir können anfangen, ja.
Guten Tag Frau Oberärztin.
Hallo.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen,
haben Sie kurze Zeit?
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Peter Lindermann, 68-jähriger Patient, ist 1,79 m groß
und 74 kg schwer.
Herr Lindermann beschwert sich über heute Morgen aufgetretene Melena.
Er ist mit einer Einweisung von seinem Hausarzt weit und zu gekommen.
Er leidet auch an seit 2 Wochen bestehende epigastrische, drückende und redizivierende Bauchschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen würden in den Rücken ausstrahlen und die Intensität bewertet Herr Lindermann als 5 auf einer Schmerz.
Er hat dann angegeben, dass er auch Inaptanz hat und er hat schon 2 Mal erbrochen.
Blut immer brechen und kaffeeartiges Ersatz wurden verneint.
Er leidet auch an seit 4 Monaten redizivierende Diare und Obstifatioen.
Übrigens meldet er über Fatigue.
Die übrige vegetative Anamnese ist unaufwählig bis auf Insomni, Parasomni, Necturie, 2-3 Mal pro Nacht
und Gewichtsverlust, ungefähr 10 kg seit 6 Wochen.
Anvorerkrankungen leidet er an Diabetes mellitus type 2, Altheria l'ericatoni, Coxarthrosis
aber da geht er keine Medikamente ein, nimmt nur über Prof. 600 mg bei Bedarf ein.
Beide Patients erfolgt eine Translektomie im Kindesalter.
Bei ihm ist Novalgin und Jodh Allergin bekannt.
Er reagiert darauf mit Disney und Exantin.
Er ist Raucher, da gibt es 35 Packungsjahr.
Er trinkt jeden Tag 2-3 Bier Gläser Bier und auch Schnaps.
Er ist verheiratet, lebt mit seiner Frau und hat 2 Kinder.
Er ist im Rente, vorher war er Automekaniker, er treibt keinen Sport.
Er hat in der Familienanamnese angegeben, dass sein Vater mit 65 gestorben.
Die Mutter hat an Depression gelitten und auch mit 65 gestorben.
Ansonsten gibt es keine Aufhelligkeiten bei der Phananmese.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Magenkaetrinum.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen in Betracht,
vielleicht Özerfaguskaetrinum oder Urkusventrikuli.
Vielleicht Kolonkaetrinum.
Haben Sie mal nach Özerfagusbeschwerden gefragt?
Darüber haben wir nicht gesprochen, aber das mache ich sofort.
Was machen Sie jetzt von der Diagnostik mit dem Patienten?
Zuerst würde ich Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Ob es eine Hypertension gibt, das ist sehr wichtig.
Dann würde ich den Patienten pfleglich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie da in Besonderen?
Bei der Instruktion kann ich Blässe entdecken.
Beim Abtasten kann es auch eine Spannung sein.
Vielleicht auch Tashkardi kann man entdecken.
Was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Blutbild.
Etidrositvert, hemoglobin ist wichtig.
Was erwarten Sie?
Was könnte er niedrig sein?
Was kann er niedrig sein?
Hab ich.
Wegen Blutung?
Ja, genau.
Was für Werte lassen Sie noch im Labor bestimmen?
Eigentlich gibt es hier eine Meilignität.
Deswegen möchte ich den Allgemeinzustand genau sehen.
Ich würde viele Werte sehen.
Worauf würden Sie achten?
Zumormarkt.
Was machen Sie an operativer Untersuchung?
Dann würde ich einen Abdomencer durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie da zu sehen?
Dadurch können wir es morgen entdecken.
Schlimmstenfalls.
Wenn die Sonografie jetzt verdacht bieten würde,
würde man dann noch weiter machen?
Endoskopieren.
Dadurch können wir auch die Blutung stillen.
Das wäre sicherlich der nächste Schritt in der Diagnostik.
Würden wir den Patienten auf alle Fälle zu diagnostischen Zählen aufnehmen?
Ja, natürlich.
Gut.
Ich bin gespannt, was Sie für Untersuchung herausbekommen.
Was Sie mir hinterher erzählen, was Sie bei dem gefunden haben.
Dann lassen Sie mich nachher wissen, was daraus geworden ist.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Lassen Sie mich wissen, was Sie bei Ihren Untersuchungen herausgefunden haben.
Sie sollen sich um den Patienten kümmern.
Ich erzähle jetzt, was ich herausgefunden habe.
Nein, das war nur Ende dieses Gesprächsabschnittes.
Irgendwie müssen wir einen Punkt machen.
Die Oberärztin sollte nach ihrem Patienten schauen.
Mir sind ein paar sprachliche Sachen.
Ich bin jetzt wirklich mal kleinkariert unterwegs.
Was Sprache angeht.
Einmal, genau, was immer wieder kommt.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Durch Schlafstörungen, Nektorie, Appetitlosigkeit und Verstopfung.
Dann ist die nicht mehr unauffällig, sondern die ist auch.
Da kann man nicht sagen, sie ist unauffällig bis auf.
Wenn ein Kriterium vielleicht irgendwie, dann kann man sagen,
alles andere ist okay.
Aber wenn der eine ganze Handvoll Symptome hat,
kann man nicht mehr so richtig sagen, dass das unauffällig ist.
Dann haben Sie einmal beim Patienten
und auch einmal beim Oberärztgespräch,
dieses Kaffeesatz, ähnliche besprochen.
Wissen Sie, was damit gemeint ist?
Was ist Kaffeesatz?
Ich möchte über Hermathemesis fragen.
Ja, genau.
Aber was ist im deutschen Kaffeesatz?
Wenn ich Kaffee aufbrühe,
bleibt das, was im Filter über.
Dieses nasse, dunkelbraune Zeug.
So sieht ein blutiges Erbrechen aus,
wenn das schon eine Weile angedaut ist.
Da sagen wir dann eben,
beim Patienten würde man sagen,
sah das aus, die Kaffeesatz?
Und beim Arzt würde man dann vielleicht sagen,
er hat kein Kaffeesatz ähnliches Bild gesehen.
Dann ist mir eine kleine Sache aufgefallen,
die ist mir letztes Mal schon aufgefallen,
aber dann habe ich aber nicht gesagt.
Wenn Sie gerade anfangen mit der Anamnese,
sagen Sie, das ist so wie ein Patient,
und dann sagen Sie, er beschwert sich über,
das ist eine ungewöhnliche Formulierung.
Wir sagen zwar, er hat Beschwerden in der und der Hinsicht,
aber wenn sich jemand beschwert,
dann sagt er, hören Sie mal,
ich habe hier schon eine ganze Stunde gewartet,
und es passiert immer noch nichts.
Beschwerde hat irgendwie zwei Bedeutungen im Deutschen.
Einmal, die Beschwerden ist etwas, was mir weh tut,
wo ich sage, das macht mir ein Problem.
Und ansonsten ist die Beschwerde dieser aktive Vorgang,
ich gehe irgendwo hin und sage, hey,
Sie haben mich schlecht behandelt,
oder ich war aber erst in der Schlange,
Sie haben sich vorgedrängelt,
oder ich kann nicht auch bei meinen Vermieter beschweren,
dass meine Wohnung nicht warm wird,
oder dass das Wasser nicht läuft.
Das ist eine Beschwerde.
Und die klassische Formulierung,
also hier tausendmal gehört,
stellt sich vor wegen.
Das ist eigentlich so dieses Übliche.
Erklagt über Beschwerden im Hinblick auf.
Oder erklagt über Beschwerden,
wie gesagt, hat hier im Deutschen
irgendwie so einen anderen Hintergrund,
eine andere Nebenbedeutung.
Würde ich einfach der Klarheit will,
anders formulieren.
Habt ihr echt einen Junior?
Noch irgendwas?
Ja, das war auch süß.
Sie haben gesagt,
Seien Sie nicht übel,
wenn ich nach den Drogen frage.
Seien Sie nicht übel, heißt ja,
Seien Sie nicht schlecht.
Nehmen Sie es nicht übel.
Oder ich finde immer diese Frage,
diese Frage wird durch diesen,
ich weiß, dass das alle lernen
und dass das überall in den Kursen gelehrt wird.
Ich denke immer,
wenn ich diese eigentliche banalen Frage,
so einen großen Vorsatz davor setze,
dann wird die erst so richtig schwer gewichtig.
Und wenn ich nur so ganz auch ein paar Fragen frage,
haben Sie jemals Drogen probiert,
dann gehe ich da so drüber weg.
Aber wenn ich, nehmen Sie diese Frage jetzt bitte nicht übel,
dann fokussiere ich den Patienten darauf nach dem Motto,
das ist ja eine ganz intime Frage.
Als Frau würde ich manchmal vielleicht sagen,
die Frage nach einem Gewicht ist viel indiskreter.
Aber ja, oder was war es,
ich die Frage nach Alkoholkonsum,
weil das liegt ja wirklich auf der Hand
und da möchte ich auch wirklich wetten,
dass kein Patient Ihnen eine ehrliche Antwort gibt in Deutschland.
Also die trinken alle mehr, als Sie sagen.
Da würde ich wirklich drauf wetten.
Die geben ganz bestimmt nicht die richtigen Mengen an.
Genauso auch die Raucher.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die eine Packung am Tag oder zwei zugeben.
Die werden das immer bargartalisieren.
Und wenn die aus jeder Pore nach Mikrotin stinken,
werden die immer sagen, ach, ich rauchst doch fast gar nicht mehr.
Also, na gut, okay.
Aber wie gesagt, nicht seien Sie nicht übel,
sondern nehmen Sie nicht.
Nehmen Sie die Frage bitte nicht übel.
Nehmen Sie die Frage.
Also das war jetzt wirklich auf sehr hohem Niveau gemeckert,
sage ich jetzt.
Das waren wirklich so Spitzfindigkeiten.
Super fand ich das wieder.
Diese ganz tolle persönliche Zubehren,
immer mit einem Namen angesprochen.
Immer sehr nett und zugewandt.
Auch sogar der Oberärztin gegenüber.
Das fand ich sehr positiv.
Und eine Formulierung hat mir natürlich sehr gut gefallen.
Ertreibt keinen Sport.
Ja, wunderbar.
Sporttreiben.
Ich glaube, kein Deutscher benutzt das so schön.
Wir sagen das zwar, treiben sie Sport,
aber die meisten sagen eher,
so ein bisschen mal machen sie Sport oder irgendwie sowas.
Sporttreiben ist wunderbar formuliert.
Nein, Ihr Deutsch ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr gut.
Deswegen habe ich auch auf so Kleinigkeiten
ein bisschen rumgeritten.
Das ist wirklich nur so schleifen an Feinheiten.
Aber ansonsten würde ich sagen,
war das ein Top-Anamnese-Gespräch und auch eine sehr gute Schilderung.
Vielen Dank, das ist deine.
Sie müssen sich glaube ich wirklich überhaupt keinen Kopf um ihre Prüfung machen.
Ja, das läuft.
Also da möchte ich meine Hand für verbetten.
Das muss zwar nicht unverzichtig sein,
aber nein, das muss auf alle Fälle laufen.
Ja klar, ist ja noch ein paar Tage hin.
Alles klar.
Dann schreibe ich nicht mehr einen Fall.
Noch so warm mit.